hasta ahora hemos visto cómo usar
subdivisiones para crear las superficies
que definen las formas de nuestros
personajes en esta lección vamos a
profundizar en las matemáticas detrás de
los promedios ponderados y justo como en
la anterior vamos a empezar con una
versión muy simple vamos a analizar
curvas en 2d antes de analizar las
superficies en 3-d y vamos a ver que la
subdivisión puede ser muy flexible eso
significa que podremos obtener un montón
de resultados simplemente jugando con
los diferentes pesos para continuar con
nuestro estudio de promedios ponderados
recuerda que en la lección sobre
modelado ambiental analizamos las medias
ponderadas de dos puntos entonces
empecemos esta elección con un repaso
escribimos el promedio ponderado m de
dos puntos ahí ve como m es igual a 1 -
t por a más de por b el parámetro te
controla el peso y por lo tanto la
posición
la que m se encuentra a lo largo de ahí
ve recuerda que los pesos de ive tienen
que sumar 1 para representar un promedio
adecuado podemos reescribir la expresión
para m en una forma en la que sea más
fácil agregar más puntos y es así m es
igual a a minúscula x a más de minúscula
por ver todo esto dividido entre a
minúscula más b minúscula observa que
tenemos que dividir todo entre a
minúscula más b minúscula para que la
expresión sea un promedio adecuado la
geometría de esta forma más simétrica
dice que la razón de las longitudes a m
y mb es de minúscula / a minúscula ahora
generalicemos para el caso del promedio
de tres puntos m es igual a a minúscula
por a más de minúscula por b más se
minúscula por c todo esto dividido entre
a minúscula más de minúscula más e
minúscula
la geometría dice que las áreas sub
triangulares son proporcionales a
minúscula b minúscula y c minúscula aquí
todos los pesos son 1 así que m es el
punto medio y todas las áreas son
iguales supongamos que queremos hacer
que el peso debe sea del doble del peso
que a osse el álgebra será m es igual a
a más 2 b c y todo esto dividido entre 4
la geometría dice que el área del
triángulo opuesto a b es del doble de
grande que las áreas en los otros dos
triángulos aumentar el peso debe a 29 m
más cerca de b y al aumentarlo a 3 se
acerca todavía más
al fijar el peso de a en cero significa
que ya no tiene importancia
entonces m está en algún lugar de la
línea entre b y c
me encanta esta conexión entre el
álgebra y la geometría y eso es porque
es muy elegante y también muy útil
muchas veces el problema se resuelve
mejor analizando la geometría y otras
veces analizando el álgebra es muy
importante tener soltura en el siguiente
ejercicio vas a probar que también has
entendido este concepto
sin duda podría haber dicho esto en
inglés
interactive